Just come back to Muhammad for one
second because it's quite an
extraordinary story.
>> A man, not particularly anybody really,
preaches the revelations that he's got,
gets chased out of the city he's from,
goes to another city, and then suddenly
he's a warlord who effectively conquers
a huge swath of land. Uh, what do we
know about Muhammad that meant that he
was able to do this? Keep in mind, by
the time he dies, it's not really a huge
swath of land. We're talking about the
Arabian Peninsula, which looks large,
but it's mostly desert. Yeah. And he has
control over various tribes. And I I
think what you're getting at is one
century after Muhammad, Islam now
governs all of North Africa, all of the
Middle East, and is in the middle of
France. So that's the the historical
kind of um conundrum that a lot of
people have been wondering about. How
did it does of course start with
Muhammad?
>> Yeah. And you know, how did it go from
this guy who was just sitting in a cave
talking to Gabriel to a century later
essentially, you know, they've conquered
most of what was the old Roman world and
most of it on Christian territory and
even further east into outside of the uh
Roman Christian world. So that's always
been the great riddle. And um earlier
historians, including those who were
contemporary, believe it would it had to
do with the fusion of jihad, the
doctrine of jihad. Because up until then
um look you had war people engaged in
war non-Muslim non-Muslims engaged in
war Christians engaged in war but it had
especially with Christians it became a
just war type thing and there were
limitations to how you can do it but
with Muhammad he basically what I always
say is the genius of Muhammad which goes
to your question is that he basically
fused the the sort of tribal mores of
his society and rearticulated them
rather than fused but he fused them with
theology and rearticulated
through sort of a a theological
paradigm. So they became okay. So what
is tribalism? The tribalism of Arabia
which also prevailed in most tribal
societies, pastoral societies, was
basically what is tribalism? It's me and
my kin. You know that's it. Everyone
outside of the tribe is the enemy.
That's how tribalism works. It's not
that we're not your friends. You are the
enemy. You exist for me to kill and
plunder and enslave and do whatever
with. And the tribe of course you know
the f the closest is the you know the
the the nuclear family and then it keeps
spreading you know cousins and so it
keeps growing. What Muhammad did is he
maintained that paradigm which was
integral to the Arab society that he was
born in but like I said he re
rearticulated with these Islamic
teachings. So now you still hate people.
The Quran commands pe Muslims to hate
not outside tribal people but anyone
who's not a Muslim. And you can see how
that's tribalistic because we are the
ummah, right? The the nation, we are the
Muslims. Everyone outside of it, we are
commanded to hate. And this is in the
Quran. This is Quran 64 where Allah says
you have a good good example in Abraham
or Ibraim. Um because and so and this
gives you another really good example of
what I'm talking about how how um Islam
appropriates the biblical figures but
recasts them in a way that validates
itself. So they say so we know the
Abraham from the Old Testament in the
Bible. He leaves what God calls him. He
leaves what is it the land of and you
know he begins the great migration uh
towards the holy land which eventually
gets conquered Joshua etc. But when he
leaves Abraham in the Bible there's
nothing about hating anyone. In the
Quran all of a sudden God Allah tells
Muslims you have a good example in
Abraham because he told his kin we hate
you and enmity will last between us
until you believe in Allah alone. And so
that became sort of an Islamic and in
the Quran it also says similar things
about how a true Muslim can't he has to
have these feelings and disassociate
from his father, his mother, his
brother, his his wife. I have an Islamic
clerk recently who I translated a while
back who literally says because of this
doctrine you can as a Muslim marry a
Christian or a Jewish woman people of
the book because that is permitted in
Islam. But you have to hate them and you
have to show them you hate them. But you
can copulate with them and you know but
you always have to make sure they know
you you hate them. Okay. So this is an
ironclad teaching and as you can see how
so this is tribalism of course 101 but
now it has a theological veneer
>> and then so what what do you do in
tribes? We hate each other. Well I go
and I plunder you. Right. So that became
jihad. Jihad is warfare on the outsider
who I am already bred to hate. I I could
say I mean in a in a secular setting
tribalism not doesn't necessarily I I
wouldn't say teach you to hate the
outsider. You just fear him. They're
they're outsiders and you can kill them.
But it's much more when you really hate
that person. And this this is something
we can get into because it's really this
is the whole the heart of the matter to
me. This doctrine that I'm I'm
belaboring and it in Arabic it's kind of
it's it's a dichotoized doctrine. And
it's called alat. Two Arabic words. Wat
means loyalty and love for Muslims which
we can put that aside. And what I'm
looking at is the barat which is hatred
and enmity for non-Muslims. Okay? And so
that manifests in jihad. And then if you
die, right? So you're the warrior, you
hate the infidel, you do jihad. Now in a
secular setting, you that happens all
the time historically, even in the
present day, and people go fight to
plunder, right? But now if you win well
you get all these whatever the booty you
know animate and inanimate you can gain
and but if you die you get even more now
you go straight to heaven straight to
paradise where it's again hedonistic and
materialistic and you get women and you
know it's very carnal the way it's
described in the Quran okay you know
there's beautiful boys circulating
around looking like pearls and these are
supernatural women who you will populate
with in perpetuity who are made
specifically uh for X. Okay. And rivers
of wine, etc.
>> Rivers of wine.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Now, you can drink wine once
you get to heaven, but not here.
I'm sorry. Maybe rivers of honey or
wine, but I know there is wine.
>> Yeah. Sorry. I just that just took me
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It might something I'm
I'm being it's poetic language is being
used and I you know, but definitely but
I know I do know alcohol is permissible
then because that's something they talk
about. Um, so my point is the genius of
Muhammad, if you're asking, is that he
just took that tribalism but
rearticulated in a way that it became a
win-win thing. So now when I go and
plunder the outsider, the non-Muslim,
the infidel, I'm the good guy now. I'm
pious. And if I win and I subjugate,
kill, whatever, take and conquer, well
then, you know, I'm I'm even more
righteous. And if I die, I get the
highest level of paradise. So that was
one of the earliest um interpretations
by non-Muslims as to what as to the
efficacy of jihad. It's not very popular
nowadays. You know, your your average
secular historian will laugh at this and
tell you no, no, but but your average
secular historian will also tell you no
one really knows how to explain the Arab
conquests and how rapid they were
because uh you know they shouldn't by by
any means they should not have done what
they did. The most popular theory is
that the two contending powers that the
Arabs eventually in the seventh century
conquered Rome or Bzantium and the
Cassanian Persians were so weak because
they had been fighting each other. So
that's kind of the most popular theory,
but still I don't think that's uh
convincing in and of itself.
[music]